[Musique]
bienvenue dans cette émission spéciale
journée internationale du droit des
femmes on voit par les ouvre des femmes
on veut on peut aussi parler de parcours
assez particulier avec trois invités
joséphine coleman serge et bonjour vous
êtes la mère de plaisir vous êtes vice
président de saint quentin en yvelines
vous êtes si vice présidente du conseil
départemental vous êtes donc une somme
politique
et à plaisir la journée de la femme
prend un mois un sèche cheveux ni
exactement parce que je considère qu'une
journée ça suffit pas j'aurais même
tendance à dire 365 jours c'est oui ça
se faisait trois ans
il y aura beaucoup d'action qui vont
cependant pendant ce mois dans votre vie
énormément d'activités carré marafiq
bonjour bonjour vous êtes là vous alors
vous êtes chef d'entreprise la pdg de la
maison albert elle qui la fabriquent des
glaces des stores b absolument délicieux
et des hauts fonds de ces une économie
propre un peu plus tôt aux produits
viennent d'île de france c'est ça alors
maso très majoritairement tous les
produits viennent d'île de france
j'aimerais que et de la vanille en ile
de france
afin la vanille et la mangue mais si
demain
quelqu'un donc vous pouvez me produire
en ile de france
mais si dans tous mes produits viennent
ile de france mais c'est des produits
éco-responsables voilà protection
tres aux éco responsable et donc quand
j'ai repris cette belle entreprise
j'avais vraiment à coeur de pouvoir donc
offrir à tous des produits donc avec une
traçabilité
et que le consommateur puisse réellement
savoir ce qui allait avoir dans son
assiette et vous nous raconter votre
parcours de chef d'entreprise pourquoi
absolument incroyable voilà on va parler
un petit peu aujourd'hui parce que c'est
assez formidable florence père cadets
choqué bonjour jean patrice vous êtes
avocate au barreau de versailles vous
avez un vous diriger un cabinet qui est
un cabinet essentiellement féminin donc
oui nous sommes onze au cabinet dont 10
femmes voilà alors rien c'est parfait
d'avoir essayé de trouver des hommes
mais
mais voilà n'avons eu que des candidats
beaucoup de candidatures femme quelques
candidatures hommes mais les femmes
étaient les meilleurs
cadieux et que peut-être parce que vous
dirigez ce cabinet que vous êtes une
femme allez savoir
alors on va parler donc de cette journée
internationale de la femme j'ai j'ai vu
le titre l'égalité aujourd'hui pour un
avenir durable je vous êtes un peu on
prend un peu des truc à la mode là un
peu partout dans l'écolo vivre un autre
portait l'un titre un peu bizarre un peu
les choses pourraient être plus un
peuple quand même pourquoi pour un
avenir durable mines on espère
que non
c'est le titre de cette journée somme de
1000 m2 ça va faire un peu d'écologie
oui voilà on utilise encore la femme
pour faire de l'écologie c'est simple je
pense que ça doit être écrit par un
homme extrêmement
servent à
faire réagir peut-être on va parler un
peu généralement bien après on va
discuter de chacun et de chacune de
votre vos spécialités mais
peut-être d'abord sur un sondage sur
lequel je voudrais vous faire agir on a
demandé aux français est ce que vous
vous êtes à l'aise avec l'idée qu'une
femme soit présidente de la république
est ce que vous savez combien 10 ou et
on est à l'aise peu près que vous diriez
quoi et minorités peut-être ah bon non
mais je n'ai juste pas moins 35% du soir
est une femme présidente de république
c'est pas du tout la majorité
entre 30 et 40% mais pas
il ya quand même 61%
61% qui disent oui mais moi ça m'a quand
même épaté 39 % de gens qui disent un
non serait pas à l'aise avec une femme
présente aurait pu mener en 2022 il faut
quand même s'ils étaient loin
c'est dingue non mais si tu veux dire
alors on peut parler un peu politique
cia il ya au moins il ya trois femmes
candidates 6 et 4 avec nathalie
rabe on prend le pronom celles qui
pourraient être deuxième tour c'était un
marine le pen et
valérie pécresse ça veut dire que
peut-être il ya je ne sais pas on 2% 3%
mais ça peut jouer dans une élection qui
vont se dire ben c'est une femme oui
mais ça m'étonne pas ça ne m'étonne pas
parce que on peut le voir même un niveau
je dirais inférieur si je peux me
permettre et au niveau politique on se
rend bien compte déjà du positionnement
des femmes ne serait ce qu'en tant que
mère par exemple sur le département des
yvelines on a quand même pas une
majorité de femmes qui sont mères ou
alors elles sont maires de petites
communes vous êtes le maire de la plus
grande ça oui
voilà prévenus exactement et ce qui est
très de rambouillet mendoze louis il ya
rambouillet est ce que je veux dire par
là c'est que je peux vous donner deux
petites anecdotes la première c'est que
quand j'ai été élu maire
un homme politique que je ne nommerai
pas m'a dit vous rendez compte que vous
allez gérer une ville de 30 mille
habitants
j'étais quand même assez surpris je me
suis dit est ce que tu aurais posé cette
question à nos mairies du coup ça à
faire peut-être pas ça c'est quand même
étonnant et on m'a aussi dit une fois
vous souriez trop madame le maire quand
on est maire on doit être beaucoup moins
souriante que ça ça sent quand même des
choses qui font écho aux fêtes et aux
pourcentages inquiétant de personnes qui
se disent mais non une femme peut pas
prendre humains positionnement important
valérie pécresse disait d'ailleurs
elle-même y en a marre qu'on dise
toujours qu'on doit être vice présidente
mais jamais présidente de quelque chose
c'est quand même assez étonnant c'est
quand même assez étonnant on n'a pas
fait beaucoup de n'a pas beaucoup évolué
et est ton nom mais juste pour compléter
ce que vous dites donc les plus un peu
plus dans mon domaine on doit avoir une
parité sur les listes électorales
dans les entreprises quand il ya les
élections de représentants du personnel
est donc maintenant ça doit être une
femme un homme ou un homme une femme et
c'est systématiquement un homme une
femme là oui une femme un homme une
femme et géniaux ici j'ai regardé par
exemple les stadistes et alors c'est
vrai que puisqu'on parlait de politique
la loi sur la parité a quand même changé
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui il ya des
fameux paysage politique a changé ce
soit ce soit dans les mairies que ce
soit dans les assemblées que ce soit
l'assemblée nationale au sénat mais j'ai
regardé quand même dans les départements
il ya combien 80 peu plus de 90
départements en france à il ya des
femmes oui de conseils résultat
départemental oui oui on va dire m et il
y en a très très peu on s'en aperçoit cc
on n'avance pas très vite la parité a
permis à des femmes de prendre d'avoir
le courage d'y aller parce qu'il ya
aussi ça il ya ce n'est pas une question
de compétence et une question de courage
et une question de positionnement et on
se rend compte que effectivement quand
on monte une liste électorale et on sait
qu'il faut la parité c'est pas toujours
simple de trouver les failles ou
seulement parce que les femmes sont
toujours occupés à d'autres choses et
surtout je le dis elle ne se sentent pas
forcément capables il ya quelque chose
qui fait qu' elles sont toujours en
retrait dans l'éducation interculturelle
et on le sent véritablement encore une
toute petite anecdote c'est que en
recevant les personnes qui viennent pour
se présenter je dirais que dans une
liste électorale au niveau municipal
j'ai vécu ça les hommes quand ils
arrivent ils présentent tout de suite
leur pedigree avec tout ce qu'ils ont
fait tout ce qu'ils savent faire les
jeux doit creuser pour savoir pourquoi
il s'engage en tant que homme politique
dans la collectivité les femmes s'il
inverse elle arrive et a10 je viens
parce que je veux m'engager au niveau de
la ville pour les citoyens et c'est moi
derrière qui doit gratter pour savoir ce
qu'elles font dans la vie quelles sont
ces incroyables à une démarche
complètement différente des hommes et
des femmes et des compétences on est
identique bien sûr je porte aucun
jugement de qualité mais c'est vrai que
l'on ressent encore ça cette difficulté
de positionnement des femmes politique
en tout cas lui même dans les
entreprises parce que bon il ya juste
une petite anecdote sirima vous allez
chefs d'entreprises de commerces sur
vous tous et à la chambre de commerce et
d'industrie un complexe de telus voilà
je suis donc du coup pas doublement ému
un fonds de commerce versailles yvelines
et la chambre de commerce paris le
français et où j'étais vraiment en fait
séduite par le programme donc bas de
notre président
une glycine baryton et roche ne s'était
pas oublier c'est pas obligatoire dans
le l'obligatoire aujourd'hui c'est
quelque chose d'acquis
on pousse vers cela mais après donc
chaque président donc du coup porte
réellement ce qu'ils le fassent par
rapport à ce que sa façon de penser le
seul à agir est donc très clairement
enfin moi je parle en toute transparence
il m'avait contacté en me disant voilà
donc j'ai eu ton contact parce que par
l'aria et les femmes donc dans
l'industrie agroalimentaire en fait dit
comme ça en fait des parents vous voyez
on y met vous êtes un ovni chieux non je
ne comprends pas le terme ovni et c'est
vrai qu'après j'ai réfléchi mais c'est
vrai que dans l'industrie
agroalimentaire c'est un milieu où on
est à massagno de l'équipe
et c'est vrai que fin souvent moi que ce
soit enfin plus dans des réseaux auquel
j'appartiens quand j'arrive on me dit
mon alors c'est l'entreprise de ton mari
et l'entreprise à ton papa l'a dit ça
j'ai dit elle tout à fait justifié oui
c'est ça veut dire ou alors elle a
hérité
batucada partir d'explication alors que
bon nombre
de
petites anecdotes s'est conclue au medef
daisy bean et je suis la seule femme
actuellement au conseil d'administration
parce que vous aviez
ya des élections à la fin de l'année
voilà enfin c'est pour ça que la loi sur
la parité a quand même fait du bien
parce que si on dit il fallait obligé
quoi un moment non être non c'est pas
très beau c'est à dire c'est toujours
pareil c'est qu'on a l'impression qu'on
nous faire un cadeau et c'est à dire
c'est ressenti comme ça aussi par pas
mal d'hommes qui nous disent ah oui mais
évidemment vous êtes plus nombreuse
maintenant parce que il ya la parité qui
se son équipe s'est mise en place mais
ça a donné un coup de
sûr mais ça il faut la nouvelle cei
avait c'était c'était là la femme de
l'adjoint magasins ce qui soutenait
beaucoup la parité est là et à l'époque
il est alors pourquoi il n'y a pas
de jeu c'est pas des noirs
et elle disait oui attendait le lumen et
elle est la seule la salle division deux
parties à peu près égale ces hommes
femmes c'est pas c'est pas le reste donc
ça se voit
en fait on est obligé de tout le temps
passé par là haut est
passé derrière c'est en fait ben voilà
aujourd'hui vous c'est le scénario où
vous avez senti que nous on fait avant
on se dit bon voilà parce qu'il faut la
parité et du coude à la question qu'on
se pose qui est légitime ou pas c'est en
tout cas c'est le ressenti
c'est est ce que c'est ce que j'ai fait
qui a fait que donc du coup on a essayé
de me connaître pour pouvoir être à ce
poste là
où est ce que c'est la parité donc
aujourd'hui on a encore
et du coup à hong hong et tourner cette
question de légitimité mais il ya la
fameuse phrase de france as wihr où
l'égalité sera parfaite quand une femme
incompétente sera nommé ministre
[Rires]
est quelque chose qui est quand même
changé aussi beaucoup c'est qu'à un
moment quand aimé des femmes ont les
cantonner à domaine de la petite enfance
des handicapés on a une femme ministre
de l'intérieur ministre de la justice
ont une femme ministre de la défense
ça change un peu ça avance un peu mais
malgré tout si vous regardez bien au
niveau politique vous avez dans dans des
les délégations qui sont données en
général même en tant que vice-présidente
et bien on se retrouve très souvent avec
ma culture je suis athée la culture et
au tourisme et à la culture donc voilà
je viens de là donc ça paraissait un
petit peu légitime mais c'est vrai que
j'ai déjà demandé dans d'autres secteurs
le développement économique par exemple
et ça paraissait abscons que je puisse
intéresser au développement économique
alors que je veux dire c'est quand même
oui oui oui mais si c'est encore pas ça
vous avez des élus qui sont pas je
dirais aujourd'hui des femmes qui ne
sont pas apportées à être aux finances
par exemple au juridique c'est assez
compliqué même dans les collectivités et
au niveau des agents des collectivités
c'est la même chose vous regardez on
essaye de travailler sur les égalités
bien sûr au niveau des salaires c'est
moins dix de ces mois compliqué au
niveau des agents puisque ce sont des
fonctionnaires pour la plupart mais en
tout cas vous pourrez constater que les
femmes vont aussi plus dans certains
secteurs que d'autres mais parce
qu'elles ont la pression qu à un plafond
de verre pour elle la fête demain il y
avait une étude d'ailleurs qui était
très frappant que c'était sûr alors ou
lycée elles sont meilleures que les
garçons et et quand on regarde les
grandes écoles ya plus de garçons que de
filles parce que avons moins une sorte
de plafond de verre comme ça et dire non
c'est parfait pour les filles
mais sait on le remet dans la seine
vous étiez adjointe au maire de plaisir
non précédée de deux demandes tu as
promis ça et comment ça s'est passé
comme
vous dites en gros ce mois je vais pas
fait très attention au fait que ça voilà
que le gaver des gens qui râlaient parce
que j'étais une femme ou pas c'est vrai
je sais pas pourquoi j'ai jamais
ressenti ni que j'avais plus de place
que les autres équipes que je devais la
faire ni qu'on le donnait parce que
j'étais une femme et que voilà j'aime et
j'ai vécu ça avec un grand naturel c'est
à dire que peut-être parce que je suis
rentré en politique par le biais de la
culture qui était ma compétence puisque
je t'ai metteur en scène et comédienne
donc c'est vrai que
voilà on m'a appelé pour donner un coup
de main sur une collectivité pour
développer la culture donc ça m'est
apparu presque comme une continuité de
me demande job précédent donc j'ai pas
ressenti ce côté politique je suis très
honnête par contre avec le temps je me
suis rendu compte de l'ampleur de la
chose et après en devenant maire
forcément là j'ai pris cette conscience
mais je vais vous faire une
je vais pas vous raconter une anecdote
mais je vais vous faire une confidence
je vois autour de moi les hommes quand
il rentre dans une fonction élu député
maire à partir du moment où ils le sont
ils le sont véritablement c'est à dire
qu'ils ressentent ils le vivent ils sont
là vainqueur il s'incarne et il incarne
même si les compétences sont pas là je
le dis ouvertement pour les femmes
femmes en ce qui me concerne quand j'ai
été élu maire il m'a fallu des mois et
des mois et des mois pour me sentir mer
c'est à dire que quand on disait bonjour
madame le maire jde fois je me
retournais pas parce que ce fait
caricatural je me disais est ce que
c'est vraiment moi parce que la fonction
me paraissait tellement pas importante
mais forte puissante que je me disais
est ce que vraiment je suis à ma place
j'avais encore ce sentiment là est ce
que ça vient du fait que je suis mis
migrer par mes parents et tout ça il ya
peut-être un peu de ça ce côté vous
savez on parle beaucoup de l'imposture
oui ces positions restent sûrs et
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans la culture
parfois
heures
donc peut-être je sais pas trop si ça
vient du monde culturel ou du ou de la
partie immigrants je sais pas trop mais
en tout cas j'ai encore ce sentiment là
parfois et je sens bien que je suis je
ne le sens paray pas comme ça peut-être
mais je me sens peut certainement mois à
l'aise que certains hommes dans la même
fonction oui ou oui enfin
cela dit des électeurs
vous avez terrible très facilement à
chaque fois un donc ça ça donne quand
même une légitimité la légitimité la
vous posez plus la question non mais ça
s'acquiert petit à petit je pense que
quand on a une conscience de
l'importance du rôle que l'on a en tant
que mère parce que c'est pas uniquement
une vitrine et un coup de projecteur
bien je crois que il avant de l'incarner
profondément il ya une prise de
conscience qui est très très lente
vraiment très très lent et pourtant dieu
sait si comme toutes ces dames qui sont
ici on bosse comme des malades parce que
les femmes travaillent beaucoup mais les
hommes aussi parce que je vais pas non
non non non c'est pas une guerre mais
vous êtes tout bardon maire de vous avez
des enfants ça a été difficile de
concilier les deux parce que parfois
vous ai dit vous êtes dit parce que vous
étiez très occupé par vos jobs les unes
et les autres vous êtes dire on ne
pourrait être plus présente pour nos
enfants
sentiment de culpabilité parfois parce
que ça aussi on fait peser sur les
femmes bien sûr sort ça vous est un
sport ni complètement alors davantage
d'être en profession libérale c'est que
on peut rentrer un peu plus tôt puis on
va commencer à bosser vers 22 heures
mais
la petite anecdote c'est que j'avais
promis à mon fils qui étaient en
maternelle de d'aller faire
la chasse au lapin de pâques avec lui à
la maternelle et jeu donc ça c'était 15
jours avant et puis je le dépose à la
maternelle et je dis bon bah ce soir un
histoire bien lâche à dix mais maman
c'est aujourd'hui la chasse au lapin de
pâques tu m'avais dit que tu venais et
j'avais une audience à 9h à versailles
et j'avais totalement oublié et mon fils
m'a regardé et il m'a dit ne t'inquiète
pas maman la dame l'assistante elle le
fera avec moi je suis mal je suis
reparti en l'herm volant en me disant
mais
quel beau père en
fait des bols baba
non mais c'est aussi la société qu'il
veut peser assez heureux
parce que le log le personnel père se
demande pas là
chaque fois d'accord l'école appeler
s'il ya un problème on m'appelait moi et
c'était ben oui vous comprenez votre
mari est avocat
oui moi aussi
karima ça va beaucoup ce que florence
vient de dire thé vert très jeune en
plus j'étais mère très jeune à l'âge de
19 ans et ça m'évoque beaucoup ce
qu'elle me pascal effectivement il ya
forcément tout le temps ce sentiment de
culpabilité parce que on gère déjà une
entreprise c'est donc quand on dit mais
en fin
de film et perd
tout son sens parce que on a déjà une
entreprise parce qu'il ya une
organisation mettre en place pour
fluidifier pour ben la famille
il ya déjà une charge à pouvoir élever
nos enfants leur apporter aussi un tout
ce dont ils ont besoin parce qu'on n'a
vraiment cette préoccupation de la part
de leur apporter le meilleur on fait
comme on peut souvent et donc dans le
comment peuvent en étant enfin ce chef
d'entreprise
aujourd'hui on en est et où
on a aussi envie d'exister
et je fais pour moi être mère au foyer
c'est un boulot qui a pas été vraiment
de mise en avant mais je pense qu'il va
être très très difficile je sers que
mais en fait je n'ai jamais fait donc je
pourrais pas parler c'est pour ces mères
au foyer voix c'est un boulot qui est
très difficile et du coup en fin de
compte c'est c'est pas un métier
aujourd'hui qu'on met en avant et et
c'est pas évident donc forcément donc
être plus c'est en chef d'entreprise il
faut concilier deux et pouvoir donc du
coup pas répondre au besoin aujourd'hui
de ce qu'on a envie de faire en tant que
personne et donc du coup de rentrer dans
cette société aujourd'hui qui est en
train de d'émerger et pour nous les
femmes ce qui est bien donc le côté
paritaire sénat-assemblée mars mais je
crois que c'est encore plus ancré
naturellement plus et que du coup la
différence donc george whalin
effectivement on n'est pas là en train
dire que les hommes font moins bien que
les femmes mais simplement que les
hommes se disent que les femmes font
aussi bien que les hommes
c'est exactement enfin je pense qu'à moi
c'est le message que je voudrais porter
et vous
ça vous pose un problème de temps parce
que on est piquant alors moi j'ai eu des
enfants très jeunes aussi j'ai trois
fils mais c'est vrai que c'était donc
pendant la période surtout quand il
était petit or la période où j'étais
mettant en scène notre donc j'étais en
tournée c'est pas puis ça oui mais
c'était pas plus simple donc c'est vrai
qu'il fallait jongler et je meurs je me
rappelle quand même mon mari ayant un
job international donc il voyage c'est
aussi donc c'était assez complexe il y
avait une organisation très très
difficile mais c'est vrai et la voici je
le dis avec tout l'amour que j'ai pour
mes enfants je suis resté trois années à
la maison ou quatre années pour parce
que j'ai eu des jumeaux donc pour
vraiment m'occuper d'eux au départ mais
qu'est-ce que j'ai été triste de réponse
je le dis mes enfants le savent et il
fallait absolument que je sorte de ça et
je sentais pourtant mon mari était un
soixante-huitard puisque jeudi il avait
fait la veille plus de 70 donc voilà il
était là dedans mais il il avait quand
même se conjuguent de la famille où
c'était moi c'était la femme
ça a été très très difficile pendant
cette période faire comprendre que moi
aussi j'avais quelque chose à faire et
quand ces jeunes femmes veulent
s'engager aux politiques parfois est ce
que le problème de la famille de
l'éducation
problème je deviens à ce moment là je
dirais quelqu'un qui essaye de
convaincre de convaincre les personnes
pour pas leur dire de laisser tomber la
famille pour leur dire qu elles doivent
aussi se faire confiance et que
l'organisation se fait à plusieurs se
fait avec la ville qui va aménager aussi
du temps puisque nous c'est presque du
libéral aussi puisque on aménage aussi
notre temps en fonction d'eux et c'est
vrai que je les aide à passer le cap
aujourd'hui c'est mon rôle c'est de
convaincre toutes ces femmes qui je sens
ce côté social parce qu'elle met en
avant surtout le côté social avant le
côté politique c'est à dire aider les
gens c'est ce qu'elle dise ce moment de
se mettre au service de et en même temps
le côté politique c'est pas quelque
chose que moi j'impose du tout mais
elles en prennent conscience avec le
temps et mon rôle aujourd'hui moi aussi
j'ai des messages a pas cessé de faire
de dire à ces jeunes femmes venaient ne
soyez pas je veux dire craintive de ses
rôles là qui sont des rôles très
importants qui vont vous épanouir et
dans lesquels on apprend énormément de
choses parce qu'être en politique sur
une collectivité un département une
agglomération en apprend beaucoup de
choses sur vous dire sur ce que vous
dites par rapport au fait que les femmes
ont envie d'apporter d'aider des autres
dans notre profession on a majoritaire
enfin majoritairement c'est une
profession qui est très féminisée parmi
les avocates il ya une très grande
partie qui font du droit de la famille
du droit des mineurs et elles le font
parce que c'est pour aider pour aider
les mineurs et qui est absolument pas
lucratif parce que le droit des mineurs
c'est de l'aide juridictionnelle c'est
bon donc droit des mineurs droit de la
famille dans le cadre de divorce qui
peuvent être particulièrement
conflictuelle et difficile et c'est vrai
que là on un taux de 2 donc deux femmes
très important et alors ce qui est
intéressant aussi c'est que pour moi ma
spécialité c'est le droit du travail
quand j'ai commencé le droit du travail
il y a fort longtemps c'était surtout
investi par les femmes
oui oui et là les hommes qui font du
droit des affaires parce que le fils la
fiscalité et le droit des affaires sont
surtout pris par majorité d'hommes ils
se sont aperçus dans le droit des
affaires au fil de l'eau fil du temps
que le droit social était quelque chose
d'important dans le cadre de d'aider
l'équipe financiers de l'équipe
financier éventuellement humain mais
d'abord une histoire d'argent pour les
entreprises et ils ont commencé à
investir cette matière mais ils
investissent sur le côté alors ils
peuvent très bien ils font bien leurs
dossiers etc mais ils sont venus à cette
matière parce qu'il y avait un intérêt
en matière de droit des affaires et pas
par intérêt de une défense pure et c est
donc ça c'est c'est quand même
relativement intéressant aussi de devoir
de constater cela et si on prend l'ailé
continue sur les avocats les avocats les
plus médiatiques alors c'est plutôt des
pénalistes c'est plutôt des offres
impasse il ya des femmes pénaliste
simplement les femmes ne se met pas
sous la lumière donc les hommes benaïssa
sur les hommes pennel alors je cite
l'exemple de mon mari qui était
pénaliste il a toujours refusé de parler
aux journalistes il a dit c'est mon
dossier ils n'ont pas à savoir ce qu'il
ya dans le dossier je leur répondais
vous à qui revient à l'audience donc lui
ce n'était pas du tout seul et lumière
mais c'est peut-être un cas un peu
particulier par rapport aux lotoises
effets des émissions et j'avais des
avocats qui m'appelait pour passer
mais je vous ai pas appelé
mais c'est vrai qu'on voit surtout des
hommes mais parce que ils ont une
précisera parce que ils ont raison
c'est très différent mais c'est vrai que
les femmes se mettent mois et
probablement c'est ce que vous disiez
c'est qu'elle se mette mois en avant et
du coup elles sont moins bons alors il y
en a qui sont un peu sous les spots
l'être mais mettrait peut-être est très
peu par rapport aux autres dit quand
vous avez commencé il y avait il y avait
pas mal de femmes dans le droit du
travail mais bon vous travaillez
beaucoup avec des entreprises des
fraudes et entreprises des grandes
entreprises
bleus vous avez jamais senti au fond que
le fait que vous soyez une femme mais on
veut poser un dans leurs rapports avec
les chefs d'entreprises
tout s'est fait de façon très facile
alors j'ai passé une histoire de
tempérament met à tousser fait sûrement
mais tout s'est fait de façon très
facile et j'ai jamais sentie à aucun
moment sauf quelques la blésoise de
certains confrères mais sinon j'ai
jamais sentie de de rejet ou de dire tu
es une femme reste à ta place quoi et
avec mes clients qui sont mes autant des
hommes que des femmes d'ailleurs j'ai
jamais eu le la moindre réflexion le
moins d'écart condamnable quoi donc ça
s'est toujours très bien passé didier
dans votre cabinet il ya dix femmes pour
un homme c'est qu'il dit force de trop
dans la façon de travailler entre les
deux avocates et les avocats oui oui il
ya une différence alors je sais pas si
c'est le tempérament de mon associé mais
c'est quelqu'un de plus alors sais pas
si c'est parce qu'à dix femmes mais
c'est pourtant il est là depuis dix ans
au cabinet donc il a dû s'habituer mais
il est plus en retrait alors que nous on
travaille portes ouvertes ça rentre ça
sort oui ça change beaucoup et alors je
peux pas en faire une généralité mais
mais là ça échange - ou s'il a un
problème il vient voir pour qu'on
échange sur une difficulté mais ils
échangent moins sûr actuellement sa vie
perso mais nous les femmes on sait que
en traîneau ça papote et baissa pas oui
aussi on a une bonne cuisine on déjeune
tous ensemble lui dire qu'il travaillait
plus que vous pas
[Rires]
d'aussi bons résultats mais peut-être
organiser
des essais c'est vrai que c'est un le
métier judiciaire d'une façon générale
se sont beaucoup féminisée le barreau de
versailles est détaché en tête choix car
ils
sont 56 tandis pour son deuxième avocat
la première femme avocat que ça date de
quand la première femme mariée une loi
qui a autorisé les femmes a prêté
serment qui est du 1er décembre 1900 est
donc la première femme qui a prêté
serment c'était le 4 décembre 1900 et je
lis mes notes parce qu'elle a un nom
compliqué sonia olga bas lachowski et
ensuite il y à jeanne chauvin qui a
prêté serment le 9 décembre et c'est
elle qui à l'initiative d'un
téléphone est la première femme à
bâtonnière donc la femme qui dirige un
ordre des bâtonniers des motoneiges moi
je dis bâtonnière parce que ça me paraît
bien comme avocate avocate sont mis
longtemps pour venir parce qu on soude
mon ami début on disait avocat moi je
disais moi même je suis avocat
m ont dit pas maîtresse non
pour être compliqué c'est compliqué ça
complique et donc je pense la première
femme avocate pardon bêta bâtonnière
elle a été élue en 1959
non jeudi le betis est annoncée à
versailles en 1919 et à paris oui c'est
en 1932 le tout doit être sur yon je
crois voilà examen mais a lâché et est
versée bar au féminin il ya plutôt des
bâtonniers on nous avons eu que quatre
femmes bâtonnière
oui là aussi il n'y a rien qui se passe
c'est donc bien le tenir je salue car
dans les détails mais c'est bien peu de
candidates donc c'est la même chose et
ça un peu de candidates sa vrai sujet
quand même le fait de surfer
c'est une fonction particulière a aussi
battu des forêts mais
pourquoi pas d'être
et à la rooney la parité obligatoire
aussi pour
pour le conseil de l'ordre donc il faut
une liste paritaire et maintenant pour
être ré du bâtonnier ou bâtonnière il ya
le bâtonnier de la bâtonnière à paris
c'est la bâtonnière et le vice bâtonnier
et à nanterre aussi c'est une bâtonnière
avec un vice bateliers donc ils sont
deux mais il y en a un qui est arrêté
puis celui des parités
grimard afrique alors on va parler un
peu de la pérade tu es donc trappe c'est
une maison qui fabrique des glaces et
des sorbets
dit d'ailleurs c'est une entreprise rse
un plus tout à fait ce que j'ai amené à
ce qu'elle soit rs ce que c'est c'est
partout mes convictions
donc on fabrique donc on est dans
l'industrie agroalimentaire on fabrique
des glaces et des sorbets et des
desserts glacés donc 100% naturel donc
c'est vraiment l'adn de la marque et
quand j'ai racheté l'entreprise en 2016
j'ai vraiment voulu donc c'est cette
partie est ce que je travaillais en
amont ce qu'on s'était vraiment dans
l'air du temps mais c'était vraiment les
prémices
du côté
engagé au consommateur parce que qu'ils
achètent au final c'est le consommateur
est là pour relever racheter la maison
bourdais plutôt professionnel c'est ça à
la maison devant des unique exemple
qu'ils veulent voilà donc du coup aux
restaurateurs donc nous prenez sa
remontée des balles de 8,5 donc il y
avait une très belle clientèle
dans en ile de france
et du coup je côté rse j'ai voulu en fin
de compte revenir mais auquel on utilise
de la lui acheter donc on a fait un vrai
sourcing produits c'est le premier truc
qu'on a fait d'ailleurs et on se disant
bon
ça que je parle de la rse donc qu'est-ce
qu'on peut aller chercher qui est à côté
moi je connaissais pas les yvelines j'ai
vraiment embarqué en fait deux pas de
chez moi en auvergne donc à vichy déduit
chine
et au j'ai toujours enfin principalement
vécu et donc du coup j'arrive en
yvelines parce que j'ai rencontrés sans
épiloguer mais j'ai rencontré donc mon
prédécesseur au sein de l'agriculture
par hasard donc on a mûri go est
vraiment fait ce que vous mettez sur god
et ses glaces élu nouveau lui dit elles
sont bonnes quand est ce que vous vendez
votre entreprise
dans l'optique de vouloir en fait
benchmark et de l'entreprise a racheté
j'y vais vraiment parce que j'avais un
poste et un poste que j'aimais beaucoup
d'ailleurs
dans lequel j'avais beaucoup évolué et
qui m'a tout appris parce que j'ai
vraiment une autodidacte est donc en
amont et du coup je vais vraiment c'est
au salon de l'agriculture pour aller
voir des copains qui avaient en fait des
restaurants éphémères qu'ils avaient
monté et je trouve ça exceptionnel parce
que bon je suis fille de restaurateurs
et toute la partie gastronomie m'a
toujours intéressé parce que j'ai grandi
là dedans et du coup je vais voir ses
copains qui m'ont achevé de stands en
stands bon bah c'est rigolo bon moi un
vrai un verre d'eau ont créé des liens
donc vraiment le côté convivial que
j'aime beaucoup d'ailleurs au salon de
l'agriculture ce qui est un vrai vrai
partage et du coup je rencontre le
prédécesseur je goûte réglages c'est
c'est super enfin ces jeunes est ce que
vous faites elle était mais vraiment
délicieuse connaît les papilles qui
s'est enfin une longueur en bouche c'est
incroyable et
alors mais je sais pas pourquoi j'ai dit
ça je suis dit mais vous vendez pas
votre boîte
e du nom
dans dix ans mais et troisième buteur
vous l'achetez celle là pourquoi me pose
la même question enfin tu là
tranquillement à mon stand je vais fêter
mes produits
donc pour moi je pose des questions
parce que j'avais en tête de pouvoir
racheter faire de devenir entrepreneur
parce que j'ai évolué dans une
entreprise de centres d'appels
et c'est un métier qui était très
difficile où je rentrais dans une petite
boîte donc de 30 salariés alors j'ai eu
un mois encore a raconté pas voter ça
vous arrive et vous êtes vous êtes né au
maroc vous arrivez en france à 6 ans qui
nous et demi exactement on parlait pas
français pas du tout et puis comme c'est
votre merde
oussama quand j'étais à ma troisième en
fait ça m'a donné une force c'est ce qui
fait que j'ai eu peur de rien après
parce que je suis arrivé à l'âge de six
ans et demi en france avec ma maman
mon père est décédé il avait plusieurs
restaurants donc à nanterre et donc à
vichy puisque amende elle a voulu partir
de cette vie un peu parisienne qui
innovait race en russie
je sais pas pourquoi mais bon voilà
et donc du coup nom s'est retrouvé donc
allé directement à mme shi et puis la
maman elle m'a dit bon ben voila tu vas
à l'école
en cp donc j'avais déjà sept ans les
autres avaient un nom de moins et donc
du coup ben tu vas l'école donc j'arrive
à l'école et je comprenais rien mais
comme si en fait fin je comprendrais
option parce qu'on disait quoi donc du
coup au bout d'armand parce que on se
moquait et donc j'ai inventé une langue
pour dire que je vois là je savais faire
je vais parler une langue mais
complètement et donc du coup
et après je me suis moins fait embêté
parce que j'ai
accès de nouvelles langues enfin que
j'avais inventé c'était une sorte de
répondants où j'ai mis des barrières et
en fait pas partie de la javel maman
donc qu'ils savaient pas lire mais oui
ça mais il a fallu que vous ou votre
mère vous avez pas timide il
faut vous appreniez quoi
j'étais vraiment content des deux ans
ses positions là où on s'en sort par les
études vous ça vous plaisait pas
tellement un les études alors bas du cou
en fait on s'en sort pas les études ça
j'ai très bien compris jusqu'en 4e et en
3e je sais pas en fait je me suis ennuyé
mais vraiment littéralement ennuis je
sais pas pourquoi je pourrais même pas
vous l'expliquer et donc du coup mais je
commence à avoir des notes maquis
dégringolé alors que j'aimais beaucoup
la lecture la lecture ça y est c'est
quelque chose qui m'a beaucoup apporté
parce que donc bâillon mais lente une
maman que savaient pas lire et écrire
beaucoup d'histoires et puis qu il veut
aussi la précarité je me suis beaucoup
d'histoire à travers les livres et c'est
quelque chose qui m'a beaucoup aidé
et donc du coup en fin de compte je
m'intéressais plus à lire des bouquins
qu'être en cours et parce que je sais
pas les matières peut-être m'intéressait
pas à part le français l'histoire mais
les matières ne m'intéressait pas et
donc du coup pas rapidement mais nous
voilà ça marche pas pour le pas vous
allez en bep comptabilité donc ce que
j'ai fait ce que vous avez fait un bep
comptabilité exacte et vous rentrez dans
ce alors vous êtes maman on l'a dit tout
à l'heure à 19 ans il faut bosser il
fait ben en fait bien
la marmite art comme on dit et vous
entrez dans cette auto prix de télévente
quel salarié puis un jour vous croisez
le pdg ou au café la machine à café vous
lui dites quoi et bah du coup en fait
d'un jeu juste avant cette entreprise
en amont j'avais fait des boulots de
vente en magasin qui m'a pas du tout plu
parce que mon en force le client alors
madame qu'est ce que je peux vous aider
alors que la fia vient d'arriver moi je
déteste ça déjà donc on préfère regarder
et puis du coup voir ce qui nous
convient et je rentre donc du coup dans
ce dans cette entreprise de 30 seriez
donc de centres d'appels donc gestion
des appels entrants et sortants et donc
pas par hasard goût d'un mois je
rencontre le pdg donc salle de pause et
du coup qui me dit mme alors est ce que
je suis et épanouie danser vous faites
est hors du coup en gt1 on était une
boîte c'était que des nanas en étais
c'était
99 % de femmes il ne s'est pas engueulé
tout
fait insulter à l'époque c'était par
france télécom n'en fera sans citer
personne mais c'était donc du coup de
dés des enquêtes de cette fiction ou de
la télévente qu'on appelle les gens
enfin vous êtes déjà dû être appelé par
des gens qui à mes yeux ouverts jusqu'à
20h pour le jour où on aura des forfaits
téléphoniques et donc épanouie n'était
pas le mot voix stéphane woods par les
horaires parce que ont commencé à 8h30
mca lenteur avec une pause de deux
heures après midi mais qui servent à
rien enfin bon bref
et donc du coup
s'épanouit
est ce que vous voulez entendre ce que
vous avez fait ce qui pourrait vous
faire plaisir ou est-ce que je peux être
honnête donc j'avais 20 ans j'étais
rempli d'entrain
et du coup il m'a dit vous avez dit sayo
net j'écoutais le mot épanouie c'est pas
le mot est d'autant plus que je m'étais
renseigné parce que ça m'intéresse et
enfin les affaires mention intéressant
ces choses par ce quelque chose qui m'a
toujours intéressé et je m'étais
renseigné sur cette entreprise et donc
du coup je vois en fait que l'offshore
avait été complètement dans avec des
prestataires donc notamment en afrique
du nord ou en inde qui volaient m qui
vendait les mêmes prestations trois fois
moins cher et une hostie enfin quand on
est 100 % dépendant de france au sol
comme et donc je lui dis je fais donc où
là vous êtes très fiable de 30 salariés
pourquoi ne pas diversifier notre
portefeuille clients et ce qui
permettrait je pense et égoïstement
aussi donc à moi et aux collègues parce
que on est en diversion ne porte qu'un
client allait chercher des
démissions à valeur ajoutée on pouvait
finir plus tôt et c'est enfin était plus
intéressante a pas se faire insulter
parce qu a raccroché au nez enfin même
si on avait cette habitude à se dire mon
porte un costume et puis ma quand on
reparle impose quoi donc c'était un peu
ce côté théâtral et kiev dans beaucoup
de métiers en fait et donc du coup là je
suis pas non c'est pas épanouissant et
je pense que faudrait il pour tout
véhicule dangereux car là ils me
regardent comme ça en disant mais qu'est
ce qu'elle raconte et puis s'en va mais
en me disant rien mais très vexé je
m'entends très bien avec lui regardez
contacte donc je peux me permettre et
une semaine après j'ai convoqué puis m'a
dit bon
diverses elle porte le cuir malaisie
voilà vous avez un bureau les pages
jaunes à l'époque car la fin
un ordi malaisie diversité portefeuille
clients alors on va passer sur l'étude a
pas pour autant mais quand vous avez
quitté la boîte vous avez aux attentes
aidé 30 salariés il avait 700 donc du
coup
après moi c'était vraiment mon job ce
que j'ai vraiment aimé
ces deux le développement donc du coup
c'est une boîte que j'ai vraiment
développé de 30 à 700 salariés mais pas
vraiment fait confiance alors que au
départ c'était quelqu'un qui était
plutôt misogyne oui le j'utilise
talibans directeur commercial de jörg y
croyez pas du tout match de fou mais
c'étaient des potes de rugby et puis
c'était me voilà à prendre une boîte et
vont utile on est français comme par
hasard me l'ont jamais des marchés et ni
cultiver le client alors la
diversification en fait je leur parlais
complètement fin oui notre langue alors
prenons donc vous jasper on vend elle
perd elle vous achetez en 2016 et sam
alors que vous aller démarcher l'accord
les grandes surfaces bondées aux
particuliers ça marche très bien ça
marche si bien que en 2019 partez en
vacances pour la première fois encore ça
c'est un vrai boulot la grande
distribution parce que c'était vraiment
un produit qui n'existaient pas donc du
coup on proposait une offre qui était
complètement à 100% naturel dans les
glaces locales et avec très peu de sucre
donc enfin moi mon souhait vraiment
qu'on aille en reprise est en tout cas
savoir un objectif à se dire mais voilà
je veux ouvrir mon usine au consommateur
est ce qui se fait pratiquement pas je
veux commencer le consommateur puisse
voir vraiment la traçabilité du produit
et notamment enfin même les producteurs
que aujourd'hui qui ont un travail et
donc du coup en 2001 effectivement donc
là on est en pleine croissance on est
rentré en grande distribution pour le
werder alors on était à la verrière
ça fait est là et donc je pars une
semaine en corse à content de partir
après avoir fait tout ce boulot de
croissance la gestion la trésorerie
qu'il fallait gérer en même temps parce
que ma une croix croissance bas il faut
maîtriser la trésorerie et c'est sur une
boîte qui avait pas très très bien
l'époque donc du coup il a fallu quand
même quelque part habiller la mariée et
du coup ne dis pas que je parte en
vacances parce que lamont je suis en
train de capoter niveau esprits falloir
que j'aille voir ailleurs pouvoir me
régénérer et
je passe ma semaine de vacances en corse
est très bien
je prends l'avion pour revenir donc à
paris et là j'ai un appel de la police
de trappeurs et qui me dit ma votre
cuisine a brûlé madame
je pensais que c'était un copain qui
faisait une blague ce que je vais
prendre la première semaine de vacances
je lui dirais tu es complètement bête
franchement
non madame votre vie n'a vraiment brûlé
et il va falloir venir les experts
arrivent dans 5 1
et là du coup
clairement un vrai choc
après tout ce boulot mais parce que vous
avez déjà vécu deux jambes heureusement
que j'étais assise dans l'avion j'ai pu
temps et du coup la question con
sur le coup on se dit vraiment est-ce
que c'est réel et moi ce qui m'a permis
de ce qui m'a permis de voir que c'est
réel c'est quand je me suis rendu sur
place
ben voyons magazine qui avait
complètement brûlé
incendie criminel incendie criminel donc
ça ça a été prouvé ma part les experts
on a toujours parlé le fin mot de
l'histoire et c'est vrai que je me suis
pas concentré là dessus parce que je
tous les amis enfin tout ce que je
connaissais même dans les réseaux me
disent mais tu sais qui a brûlé ton
usine c'est est ce que tu sais qu'il ya
vraie cuisine et du coup je disais non
je ne sais pas et c'est vrai que j'ai
pas voulu me construire dessus parce que
en fait là je suis parti vraiment
c'était la course contre la montre c'est
dans la tête ça a été je suis quelqu'un
qui est parti de rien et là je me dis
bon il faut partir de rien mais par
contre on peut pas se concentrer surtout
faut se concentrer réellement sur
l'essentiel il faut je suis responsable
de tenter larié il faut que je puisse me
concentrer vraiment sur vite trouver un
local et reprend et vite me remettre en
rayon parce que bon bah il ya une
concurrence alors
voilà vous êtes d'installer attrapant
seule vitre ou chivu qui vous est belle
et vous cherchez était si vous demandez
à votre budget parce que vous cherchez
un alors je suis en recherche dans
localement à 2,15 122 réuni 2500 m² et
lorsque vous me disiez
le tour c'est téléphoné me disais c'est
celle des yvelines
alors oui cela veut dire enfin ah bon
alors
vous avez une burn
je suis du genre à dire basse des
blessures que peu d'économies
référence et en plus c'est une mission
qui me porte à coeur parce que
aujourd'hui étant élu cci il faut faire
venir des entreprises mais c'est vrai
que moi et ans et j'ai été confronté
donc pas trouvé de local je suis
toujours en mode
provisoire un peu enfin chez métro qui
ont la gentillesse parce que maintenant
ça va faire deux ans ni bientôt trois
ans il faut que je parte parce que il
faut qu'ils récupèrent leurs locaux eux
et enfin que je trouve quelque chose et
vu que je mais comme j'étais attaché aux
yvelines et encore plus maintenant en
tant qu'élu mais c'est vrai que le vous
permet de dire que l'on informatiques
dans les yvelines c'est vraiment une
terre qui est riche tous les producteurs
sont juste à côté soit la ferme de
grignon que ce soit fin juin tous mes
produits temps à côté on a vraiment très
fort elles érigent agriculture sauf que
on a un problème c'est le foncier
est de trouver aussi dans un problème
vous avez
mal nous on a lu foncier sur sûr plaisir
puisqu'on est dans une zone entre la
zone des gâtines et les hommes de ste
apolline on a développé une zone qui
s'appelle la zone high-tech et qui est
une zone justement en ouverture aux
entreprises alors je sais pas si vous
avez par dont on va parler entre lula
ben je sais pas si vous êtes rapprocher
de saint quentin en yvelines par rapport
à ça et normalement là il ya il ya des
choses qui se développent actuellement
donc je sais pas vous en met on peut en
parler rohff éventuel habituellement je
les ai pas eus récemment mais
effectivement que je les ai donc
mais exactement je trouve ça
extraordinaire puis surtout vous lors de
repas repartir à zéro avec cette même
énergie c'est extraordinaire faut
absolument qu'on vous trouve quelques
mois
c'est intéressant parce que souvent je
dis c'est des mecs qui sont des battants
tout ça c'est pas vrai non pas
uniquement aux faux pas sur quel dans
quel domaine vous dirai qu'il faut
encore se battre à lons et qui est
encore les mots l'égalité salariale uni
pas encore s'il ya des femmes qui
s'arrêtent le 8 mars à 15h30 parce que
après l'on peut payer un gros c'est ça
non mais dans l univers symbolique non
mais sérieux il ya surtout un problème
au niveau des retraites il ya quand même
plus de 800 euros de différence entre
les hommes et les femmes en moyenne à
votre aide c'est énorme c'est énorme moi
oui c'est ça il ya une paupérisation
attentats qui est déjà bien implanté
mais qu'ils développent j'ai beaucoup de
contentieux comme ça sur des
problématiques sur l'égalité hommes
femmes en termes de rémunération bah oui
bah oui enfin ça fait longtemps que ça
vaut combien ça fait bien 20 ans qu'il
ya des contentieux sur ce sujet là et
c'est vrai qu'une fois j'ai entendu un
chef d'entreprise d'hier mais mais non
mais pourquoi est-ce que je rattraperai
le salaire ça fait trois ans qu'elle est
en vacances parce que congé maternité et
puis d'allonger son mental pour élever
ses enfants donc la vacance donc
pourquoi est-ce que je dois appliquer
les augmentations générales donc c'est
la loi quand même temps voilà
vous parliez de dans quels domaines
peut-être il faudrait que les femmes moi
je pense que tous les domaines doivent
être en ouverture c'est pas une réponse
de normand que je fais mais c'est ce que
je veux dire par là c'est que
aujourd'hui on a on a des secteurs qui
sont des secteurs assez je dirais
valorisant qui semble valorisant mais
c'est sûr que chez vous il ya des choses
importantes à faire est également dans
votre domaine à vous les chefs
d'entreprise c'est vrai que il y en a
très très peu il ya une émission à la
télévision qui est pas si n'ya pas
longtemps sur des jeunes qui viennent
présenter les projets des start up et
tout ça je regardais la proportion s'est
débattue mais pratiquement rasée vol
c'est presque désert c'est ça qu'il faut
aussi que les dfa mal dans ce
développement d'entreprises il ya aussi
peut-être un effort de la part de femmes
20 faut les pousser 20 juin peut-être
que la société a fait que
pour le jeu du
je peux me permettre complètement parce
qu'aujourd'hui enfin moi je vois dans
divers ce réseau quand je n'ose pas dire
j'ai quatre enfants parce que du coup
enfin du coup on va pas de solliciter
pour tel ou tel truc quatre enfants
clairement enfin vraiment pas possible
on peut mener c'est quelque chose qui
forcément et en chef d'entreprise on va
prendre 20 le congé maternité moi j'ai
toujours bossé jusqu'à la fin et prix
juste le temps de l'hospitalisation pied
voilà
c'est d'autres mais je dirais que m
wonder s'agit d'un bâti kot ministre de
la justice et à la balle pratiquement
quelques points concédés
contre une colline à tort sur le lit
enfin
il faut il faut avoir envie de le faire
mais je dirais qu'on a rien sans rien
en tout cas voilà si vous êtes une femme
il faut aller à plaisir parce que c'est
là qu'on célèbre le plus
bien avant moi pendant un mois et en
plus je voudrais juste faire un petit
clin d'oeil si vous le permettez à la
maison des femmes puisque la maison des
femmes la première est née à nanterre et
aujourd'hui il ya une deuxième maison
des femmes en ile-de-france est un
plaisir qui s'appelle calypso et qui est
une maison des femmes qui vient d'ouvrir
aujourd'hui enfin il ya quelques jours
et qui est une maison qui reçoit toutes
les femmes de façon très professionnelle
parce qu'à l'intérieur de cette maison
des femmes vous avez des gynécologues
vous avez des sages-femmes et des
psychiatres vous avez toute une série
une batterie si je peux me permettre de
médecins qui sont là pour accompagner
ces femmes et ensuite pour les orienter
je dirais pour des accompagnements très
professionnel cette maison des femmes je
suis très très heureuse qu'elle soit à
plaisir on a trouvé un très beau local
département accompagne de façon
incroyable à plus d'un million d'euros
sur l'investissement et elle est déjà
ouverte eut tiré de façon provisoire
puisque les travaux se met en place sur
la maison définitive mais je voulais
vraiment accompagner je dirais toutes
ces femmes qui travaillent à l'intérieur
et dire que cette maison des femmes est
vraiment indispensable aujourd'hui pour
les femmes souffrent et qui ont des
vraies difficultés de violences
conjugales ce que l'art en parle de
travail on parle de céleri à toulouse
damien quand on interroge les français
le problème c'est celui de violences
conjugales oui mais sans elles sont
quand même aux contres y en a beaucoup
qui je permets de faire un petit clin
d'oeil aux femmes de crem bien sûr mais
aussi des femmes afghanes et femmes
afghanes souffre énormément
oui ce film merci merci infiniment je
suis comme l'indiqué assez merci
beaucoup trafic j'espère qu'elle est
choquée bon là bas ce serait ce serait
bien d'ailleurs de refaire des émissions
pas que le barça
se faisait dans un instant on va parler
d'un philosophe qui s'appelle de
condorcet que tout le monde connaît tout
le monde connaît pour l'éducation mais
ça a été un précurseur sur le droit des
femmes nous avons parlé avec nathalie
wolf qui préface un livre de condorcet
ce qui s'appelle conseil à sa fille
[Musique]
on va continuer de parler des droits des
femmes avec vous nathalie wolf bonjour
vous êtes maître de conférences à
l'université de versailles saint quentin
et vous vous préfacé avec laure al makki
un livre de coups durs ces deux textes
de condorcet qui sont très peu connus et
on va découvrir condorcet qu'on
connaissait beaucoup pour l'éducation
qu'on ait ces blocs pour les droits
civiques aussi s'est beaucoup intéressé
était même pionnier pour les pour les
droits des femmes
c'est vrai qu'il n'est pas très attendu
pas très attendu sur ce sur ce sujet
peut-être un petit mot rapide quand même
source voilà qui est condensée parce que
au fond c'est d'un no qu'on connaît mais
aucune éducation voit à peu près mais
sinon on sait pas grand chose de lui
c'est vrai que c'est un des philosophes
des lumières qui est le moins connu de
de tous peut-être assez assez mystérieux
aussi alors qui sait d'abord c'est un
grand mathématicien il a laissé une
oeuvre considérable des travaux
pionniers sur les statistiques sur le
calcul intégral sur les probabilités
c'est aussi un homme politique il a été
député en 1791 également en 1792 donc
c'est un homme des lumières
ça fonctionne débuté puisqu'il est mort
en 1794 94 exactement on va peut-être
revenir tout à l'heure mais
effectivement il fait l'objet d'un
arrêté
d'arrestation par robespierre il va il
va choisir il va se cacher pendant
plusieurs mois et puis ensuite
malheureusement il va être arrêté puis
il va mourir deux jours après dans sa
cellule la dernière très grand mystère
autour de sa mort on s'est passé s'est
suicidé on ne sait pas s'il est mort
d'apoplexie ou cibles sont encore plus
alors son corps il a été jeté dans une
fosse commune
près de bourg la reine et puis ensuite
il a été transporté alors façon très
symbolique dans un cénotaphe au panthéon
au moment du bicentenaire de 1789 nous
payer 200 ans plus tard alors c'est
aussi un philosophe un grand philosophe
un théoricien il a beaucoup réfléchi sur
le sur la question de la représentation
sur le pouvoir législatif sur les modes
de scrutin il est même à l'initiative du
référendum d'origine de l'initiative
populaire oui c'est lui le pronom voilà
énormément de choses et puis c'est un
homme des lumières donc il a une
obsession pour la justice il croit il à
une fois très très grande et bien dans
la liberté dans l'égalité dans le
progrès dans l'universel c'est vraiment
d'universalisme 1 c'est vraiment
important de ce nom de l'heureuse est
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui peuple il a
lutté vraiment elle a pris la défense de
nombreuses au privé il a lutté contre à
peine de mort c'est lui qui s'est opposé
enfin il n'a pas voté en tout cas la
mort de louis saez et puis il a été
l'avocat des protestants des juifs des
noirs c'est le premier à créer un
mouvement anti esclavagiste et puis il a
pris la défense des femmes donc ça c'est
pas tout
gala je prends juste un petit extrait
vin dans des textes parce que c'est des
textes qu'on connaît très peu un yaya
les lettres à sa fille et puis à
d'autres textes que vous avez retrouvé
que vous préférez c'est un corps elle
maquille et c'est alors par exemple
cette phrase sur les femmes par exemple
tous n'ont ils pas violé le principe de
l'égalité des droits en privant
tranquillement la moitié du genre humain
de celui de concourir à la formation des
doigts en excluant les femmes du droit
de la cité c'est quand même incroyable
certains croyaient on est vraiment avec
un homme qui est un visionnaire un
précurseur parce que
1789 90 les femmes non non pas de droit
de vote le droit de citer ses droits de
vote elles n'ont pas de droits
politiques tout simplement et lui il va
militer avec une force extraordinaire
pour ces femmes ils sont très peu
nombreux en les hommes de la révolution
a à défendre les droits des femmes et
malheureusement ensuite il faut des
rations
blue et que ça c'est pas juste le droit
de vote c'est aux veaux qu'elle occupe
des fonctions politiques les écuries
font son côté qu'il dit à cette époque
c'est c'est incroyable dit pourquoi pas
des femmes qui serait la tête d'une
armée qui présiderait un tribunal ou
qu'il est il est extrêmement précurseur
et puis surtout il a également proposé
et c'est ce qu'on essaie de montrer avec
le rhyme à quillan dans ses textes on a
eu envie de faire connaître il a proposé
une école il a pensé une école
républicaine hip hop l'école
d'aujourd'hui avant même que jules ferry
ne la mettent en oeuvre
cent ans plus tard et surtout il imagine
une école ça c'est c'est très très avant
gardistes ou les filles et les garçons
étudient ensemble mixité lamy
c'est extraordinaire c'est vrai que j'ai
découvert à travers ce texte parce que
c'est donc connaissais pas je pensais
pas que dans les années en fin de la
révolution il y avait des hommes qu'ils
soient sens aussi avancé sur le droit
des femmes c'est que c'est quand même
incroyable on les compte sur les doigts
d'une main il ya eu aussi quelques
femmes bien sur l'herbe de gouges
théroigne de méricourt
les minimes et quelques femmes qui
combat des femmes mais des des
philosophes ils ont plutôt dit souvent
ddd des choses très différentes oui
rousseau par exemple pour lui les ducs
dans les mille et dans l'éducation des
femmes les femmes sont là elles sont
éduqués pour plaire à leurs maris et il
soigne et on s'est vraiment très opposés
à l'esprit pour solistes de la même
époque et c'est intéressant au fonds aux
fins d'ordonner des techs très connu de
condorcet mais c'est assez intéressant
qu'au fond ces textes que vous avez
retrouvé vos publiées soient passés un
peu dans les oubliettes de l'histoire
tout à fait
innocent qua non c'est vrai c'est des
textes qu'on connaît mal les ce
magnifique texte qui nous a énormément
ému avec lorrain qui s'appelle conseil à
sa chine où après avoir pris la défense
des femmes s'est adressé aux femmes dans
leur ensemble à moitié du genre humain
comme il comme il le dit il va écrire à
sa fille alors il a été arrêté c'est qui
va pardon il est en fuite il sait qu'il
va être arrêté et il écrit à sa fille
elle n'a que 5 ans et il lui adresse des
conseils pour la guider sur les chemins
de la liberté sur les chemins
d'indépendance et il lui dit le la voie
du bonheur c'est d'avoir l'estiment de
soi c'est de poser son regard sur autrui
de faire attention à l'orgueil et la
vanité de faire du travail et bien
trésor d'avoir une vie à soi et pas
seulement en accomplissement dans le
mariage c'est vraiment c'est
incroyablement moderne parce que
la coupe baseball dans la famille dans
le mariage c'est encore des choses qu'on
entend aujourd'hui et qui pèsent encore
sur la on l'a vu tout à l'heure dans des
bacs on avait au fond il ya une culture
comme qui est très forte de dassier la
femme un rôle qui est le rôle de mère de
famille et 10 à 7 190
une époque vraiment on est on est loin
de mettre en application tous ces
principes puisque d'ailleurs même ses
fans quand on parlait olympe de gouges
de théroigne de méricourt toutes ces
révolutionnaires
vont voir leurs velléités d'émancipation
très vite anéanti avec robespierre et la
terreur bravo d'avoir bravo d'avoir
ressorti ses 7 ex iso donc c'est aux
éditions folio gallimard
le si on parle d'aujourd'hui au fond le
combat des femmes
iliadis y'est c'est gagné il ya au
contraire de féminité qui disent il ya
encore beaucoup de choses à faire
quel est votre point de vue là dessus
écoutez je crois qu'il faut continuer le
combat pour les droits des femmes alors
qui depuis 1944 et puis ensuite 75 a
vraiment évolué dans un sens extrêmement
positif je crois qu'on a on a qui est
bien tous les tous les droits que nous
avions à acquérir il y a maintenant
allez allez mettre en oeuvre la presse
une évolution des moeurs mais je crois
que les jeunes générations
on regarde les jeunes de 10 à 20 ans à
mon avis on est éduqué autrement et je
suis extrêmement optimiste mois pour
pour la suite il faut bien sûr continuer
de lutter contre la violence faite aux
femmes il ya certes un accompagnement à
faire y compris peut-être dans la
formation des experts des policiers des
magistrats également on voit sur ces
commence à se faire un peu mais je crois
que que nous avons gagné nos droits et
peut-être qu'il faut continuer de l'est
bien sûr de les vendre le lait garantir
de les défendre dans l'esprit de
condorcet justement avec cet
universalisme qui à mon avis est plus un
vecteur important
ça les uns contre les autres voilà c'est
ça des façons en revanche aujourd'hui je
crois qu'il faut se garder de ces
dérives qui peuvent être dangereuses et
puis se tournaient surtout
vers nos amis ukrainiens les
ukrainiennes qui sont extrêmement
courageuses aujourd'hui qui se battent
qui feront l'objet comme souvent dans
les guerres avec des crimes odieux
beaucoup de violons le on le suppose on
verra ce que donneront les choses quand
on découvrira tous ces exactions et puis
une pensée aussi vers les femmes
afghanes rappelons que ces femmes ne
peuvent plus se déplacer leurs
réseaux de lui rappeler ça c'est vrai
qu'il faut pas payer le la question de
l'ukraine mais il faut pas oublier aussi
des femmes afghanes qui souffrent
énormément plus de droit de circuler
dans l'espace public plus de droit à
disposer de leur corps est ce que de
droit de publication
voilà nicolas de condorcet conseil à sa
fille et autres textes à coup préfacé
avec laura elle maquille et c'est chez
folio merci beaucoup d'un tel vol fait
merci à tous et à très vite pour un
nouveau numéro de boeuf
[Musique]